the freak stuff in the bedroom if race
sprinkles is is put into that context
what do we think of that like how would
race be
put into the bedroom use your
imagination
[Music]
i have unintentionally been racist
towards my partner
three two one
go
i definitely i've definitely been
uh ignorant so we were
so we had an argument and i was upset
and i had previously expressed how the
the stereotype or the stigma on angry
black men or angry
black women and how that makes me feel
and so we got into an argument i was an
angry black man
but in that moment of anger he actually
called me an angry black man
which which is like the worst thing
maybe go crazy because
um that you know that was like the one
thing that i was like talk to him about
um so you know that was a really bad
fight
um and it never happened again
i feel like i mean i'm strongly disagree
but i think
as just a white person i am just
inherently ignorant
so i think i'm gonna move to somewhat
agree dating a black man has completely
opened my eyes
more than i already thought they were
open you know to be fair you've never
said anything that made me feel like
damn she's racist
i'm from the bay so it used to be in my
vocabulary where i would say the n-word
with the a i would rap it i would i
would do just those things but um my
slang in general would just
take her off and then i became conscious
of it and i really liked her
or i still do of course i love you
i started changing the way i speak i
feel like she should be over here too
um she would do uh asian accents
the only time that i feel like i
could be offending asian people is when
i'm mocking you
when you're mocking your mother
so i only do the accident when he does
it making fun of his mom
before that i never did that so okay
guys so we're going to do something
different this is called
hot tapes and basically we had our
audience submit
hot takes and assumptions that they make
about interracial relationships
they're really hot oh boy sex
gets steamy since you are interracial
[Music]
i mean i think it adds to i like the
differences between us
yeah definitely i mean there's not like
any weird role play or anything
yeah but yeah definitely you know makes
it fun
i will say like when i'm not with you
people will like be like oh
like i know why you're with the black
guy and it's like that's like super
disrespectful because it's like that's
like definitely
like on the line of like fetishizing
right a race
there's not many uh sexual stereotypes
about white men
but like walking down the street
especially um dating an asian woman
like i get looks from men all the time
being like oh
like you know right and like like people
like actually like calling me out
while i'm right next to her interracial
relationships can be a fetish
and that's okay if it's love too
even if you love the person you just
sped aside and that person is uh
good at all yeah and you're devouring
the entire community in itself
i think there's always room for growth
so i can understand if it starts as a
fetish
and then along you know the relationship
they actually fall in love with that
person and they realize that okay it
wasn't okay for me to
initially just like you based off of
that if it's between two consenting
adults the freak stuff in the bedroom if
race sprinkles is is put into that
context
what do we think of that like it's just
in the bedroom or is it like possible to
just keep it in the bedroom how would
how would race be
put into the bedroom use your
imagination
it doesn't even matter if you're
consenting or not it's still wrong yeah
right like you got
you want to say that stuff you want to
do that stuff because of the stereotypes
you have of those people
and that doesn't really sit right with
me whatsoever
i have always wanted mixed babies
three two one
go go
at one point in my life i kind of wanted
to have mixed babies with almost every
race
i don't know if that's weird but i just
wanted
i'm real into genetics i would like to
see
um how my kids would turn out and
never rest jeez as a mixed race person
myself
you don't have a group of people to
really be around i mean sometimes you
connect with
one side sometimes you connect with
another side but for me
it sucked actually a lot i've accepted
myself
i'm black and proud i love the fact that
i have both of these cultures and i
really don't care
i just have to teach my kids that
because of your skin tone you either
gain privileges or lose privileges like
i've had people at work like
we'll be talking about ourselves and
they'll i'll show them a picture of ivan
and
they'll be like oh my god i totally
wanted black babies like
when i was like a teenager and it's just
like this isn't build a bear like this
is a human
like okay so and i actually have an
eight-year-old
mixed child it's been very challenging
but i've had to stick it out because i'm
i want to be a good father and i care
about my kid
um so this isn't build a beard this is
real life
and in my mind i wanted to have kids
that was exactly my skin tone or
very close to it and look like me
because i am conceited as well
where the hell i'm gonna find somebody
to do that and it work out and they're
just a perfect wife
i don't i don't believe in that anymore
it's funny because that was
actually something we talked about when
we first started dating that became of
insecurity of mine i was like so why are
we dating
because i cannot provide absolutely any
of that for you
and so i understand like i said why he
feels that way why
a lot of the black community feels that
way um so i'm just glad that i'm
accepted now in our relationship for
that
i sometimes feel like i betrayed my own
grace
three two one
go
i definitely feel like that man i feel
like especially where i'm from
i did my people a disservice by playing
into that stereotype
and knowing what i stand for now it's
hard for me to
feel like i'm going to be taken serious
in the future if i ever want to speak on
controversial topics
my people won't respect what i say
because like it doesn't add up
my views and stuff and then i just i'm
dating somebody
outside of my race behind the scenes i
feel like i lose respect in a way
me growing up like i was never always
seen as black whether it was because of
how i looked how i talked or my culture
but then
when i get with someone who's not black
right they're like oh you're portraying
us oh like i get comments letting my
dm's be like oh
alex you're not with us no more right
and i'm like
do you want me or do you not want me you
know i it doesn't bother me if you don't
want me and i understand it is what it
is but
don't pick and choose and don't nitpick
little things right
if you want me to be part of your
community then accept me for who i am
don't
say that i'm oh because i'm half i don't
get to participate in certain topics or
certain discussions
being linked to another race has its
benefits
three two one go
um i guess i feel like the word like
linked kind of confused me because i
feel like experiencing another person's
experience like what their culture like
the way that they live is definitely
personally beneficial but i think that
like in terms of how others
view me because i'm dating a white man i
don't find that beneficial like i feel
like people might have like
preconceptions about who i am because
i'm an asian person who's chosen to date
a white man
yeah i also i had a question for i guess
other people like do you ever feel like
being with a white person like could
shield you from
like discrimination or like that they
could like stand up for you in a certain
context like if you were in like an
altercation with
the police or something like wood having
a white person there like sure right
and that's what i kind of thought of
when i heard the question and
i was listening to you it's just like i
don't know even a
customer service experience i don't know
just random experiences where the other
the person on the other side
might judge me based on
me being black but you know versus
someone else calling
or you know him calling and you know
it's a whole different experience
so they might treat you know us
individuals differently
so there might be a whole different
experience based on just that
i feel like an outsider with my
partner's family
three two one
go
so i'm sorry grace in our lives
especially today recently politics plays
such a huge part in it
and um because you come from a
conservative household it does
that's different from where i come from
and it does make me a little bit
uncomfortable to know that i'm going to
be meeting people and have to have close
relationships with them
and they don't value what i feel like i
value in my life
he's actually the first black man i have
ever dated and
the only person of color within like my
family just in of itself
and so certain members of my family um
with the same political values as us
like had to kind of confide in me like
hey
we support you with whoever you date
like we're here for you
so it was interesting to kind of see the
different sides of my family members
that i didn't necessarily know
when i met her father for the first time
we were walking to get food
and we saw the ronald reagan museum or
something like that and he's like
oh yeah i love ronald reagan right and
you can have your own personal opinions
on
uh presidents but ron reagan was like
he's like the main reason why black
people are incarcerated he's not a very
good person of black people so
i was kind of cracking up about that and
i was kind of awkward and i know you
kind of bit your tongue on that as well
it was hard to not say anything but i
was thinking about saying something to
maybe like be like i don't know about
that but i didn't want to like argue
with your father on the very first day
that i met him
yeah that wouldn't be very fun yeah
i don't know if i can exactly truly
connect with them because of that
he's a very nice person obviously and he
makes me feel comfortable but at the
same time i have to recognize
who i am as a person i would say i
somewhat agree
because with my partner's family there's
a language barrier so
i guess it's my responsibility now to
try to learn the language but sometimes
when we're together
they're talking i have no idea what's
going on so
i think that's a bit of why i feel like
an outsider but other than that
i feel welcomed i wish we were the same
race three two
one go
um i'll start i feel like uh that would
just be the default easiest way
to navigate through life
but definitely obviously growth happens
when you're
in inter-relational relationships but
yeah that's kind of why i chose someone
or somewhat agree um yeah i guess it
like you were saying like i just feel
like it would be
easier in some aspects and then for me
just like being mixed race i have felt
very like disconnected from
my culture so i feel like dating someone
from who was like chilean or who was
korean would help me
but i also agree like obviously if you
weren't white you wouldn't be like you
and so i don't like wish that and
the benefits outweigh like what i gained
i kind of sounds weird coming out
because it's like
what do you guys get out of dating white
people but like
white people i feel like we learn i
think it's interesting that everyone's
saying that
they feel it's easier because i feel
like it will be more difficult
me having a black man and raising a
black family that would be more
difficult if i was maybe with someone
who was white
who could probably have benefits
in other ways i'm grateful for my
husband and
i love being with him and i think
there's a lot of benefits um just
culturally
and you guys that is officially a wrap
[Applause]
and then we also got you some really
cute
[Music]
oh thank you so much
i know you don't wear
[Music]
you